yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
international master tongue kissed 88 so
let's check this week a pilgrim ski ok
so I'm Kingston yeah no model let's
let's play along the modern defense here
I can't hear this also he fire from but
I can also play this one it's just them
try that ok is quickly attacking the b7
pawn a knight c6 this possible 90 form
and maybe okay now II five-phase he at
one point he will take b7 okay let's so
let's protect that interesting a phone
yeah my position is more geared towards
some playing a dark squad strategy but
his pawns arm I probably need to switch
to 276 set up e 6 9075 let's see oh I
forgot about this move yeah I have no
square I only have this square and maybe
maybe i can i can i can i must play that
anyway but before maybe I can do
something with the long diagonal is this
maybe maybe save the day for the moment
I'm not that I'm not losing this night
immediately and now is probably
threatening before hmm
what deck
hmm some way to gym busy 5v5 takes takes
on d5 or something ah what the heck did
i do i wait before i can just take a
play be five but i varies i'm very slow
here my thought process before i can
just take and play b5 it's not not so
terrible of course I lost a ages on the
clock for all this yeah there's still
this idea so
before I can still take
trying to prepare be five I must be
cautious i can maybe take twice take in
and take a five ok so now if i take with
the pawn that's before so i need to take
with the night
yeah I'm not sure maybe this position
isn't so bad even but then I lost I lost
so much time
okay our queen bee six son that's 95
this was my original idea and it's not
working before his threat also okay
must must somehow take control of d5
square ok so now d 5 right g5
undermining this night I forgot about
this move what again we hit what a game
ok let's let's do that at least I've got
this this night only three but
yeah some of this game feels like I
didn't get anything right should I take
it on plane and probably probably that
one now at least I still got two pawns
strange some more both clock stand
didn't work then no okay so probably got
a substantial lack here okay Bishop you
form yeah let's take that yeah right
back to be fun it's not great check
yeah it's basically just a piece the
only slight hope is that this King is
very very slightly weakened but it's
it's nothing substantial try a try for a
moment but it's basically just a piece
mmm time morning crina here check
it can take with you can play G 10 or
anything it's not really a any thread
okay black resign yeah I basically got
into this big trouble right in the
opening I then it I'm was perfectly OK
again but it it cost me so much time
this that I overlooked there that I
overlooked all this but it somehow
seemed to to work from moment here 92
was a good move taking a five but then I
was perfectly all right again this
position is is ok Knight b6 is good for
black for example just winning the sea
porn but okay I needed to to play
quickly under and this was probably all
wrong getting getting in down yeah might
be too the computer is ruthless of
course and this wasn't working because
of before yeah it all started right in
the opening when I felt too too much
behind on time I couldn't really manage
the problems alright thanks for watching